du bassin de la villette à la ferté
milon dans le département de l'aisne il
y a le canal de l'ourcq un canal étroit
et peu profond il reprend petit à petit
du service grâce à une nouvelle activité
le tourisme fluvial de paris au terminus
on peut profiter du calme de la verdure
et du charme de la navigation
une balade qui attire de plus en plus
les amateurs de dépaysement à quelques
minutes seulement la capitale xavier
grimaud et christian welter ont tant
marqué pour nous une simple clé peut
parfois vous ouvrir les portes d'un
espace inconnu ou plutôt méconnu vous
êtes ici dans les derniers kilomètres du
canal de l'ourcq aux environs de la
ferté milon entre seine-et-marne l'aisne
et l'oise serpente la portion de la
rivière canalisée
depuis françois 1er
où
c'est un peu triste de ne voir personne
sur ce canal depuis tant d'années et
puis on retour de voyages à l'étranger
avec ma famille j'ai voulu me balader et
faire du bateau sans succès j'ai même
pas trouvé une barque à moteur enfin
absolument rien donc il est venu comme
ça on s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas
remonter le courant et puis voir si on
peut essayer de faire quelque chose sur
ce canal qui a beaucoup d'attraits
touristiques et historiques qui est
complètement au mans depuis quelques
années le canal revit peu à peu on re
découvre ses paysages tranquille grâce à
des croisières d'un jour d'une après
midi où le temps d'un repas
les bateaux sont spécialement conçus
pour naviguer sur cette voie d'eau
étroite et peu profonde
ce qui est dommage c'est que bien sûr ce
canal soit en cul de sac
le canal de soissons n'a jamais été
construits puisqu'il était question à
une époque de construire un canal entre
le canal de l'ourcq et l'aisne
mais il ya bien longtemps mais par
contre à l'ordre du jour est un projet
actuel qui est de rejoindre la marne au
canal de l'ourcq par un ascenseur à
bateaux à la hauteur de villers les
rigaud et qui serait alors un
développement touristique extraordinaire
pour la france mais en attendant le
voyage s'arrête ici à port aux perches
pour atteindre ce point le courageux
navigateur partie du bassin de la
villette aura parcouru 107 km en deux
jours et demi de navigation